good night Matthew good night Brady time to
get some sleep good night Dad good night Dad
all right let's go we're going to be late why did
you ask for a second bedtime story the first one
was scary I needed to even help once a year around
the holidays a very lucky group of hockey players
sneak away for the NHL holiday pond hockey classic
a game that defies imagination lifts up their
spirits and might even get a few of them grounded
we just got to be home before our parents wake
up you know you could have just cut
it when you landed oh yeah now before
they get started there's of course the age
old tradition of the veterans playing some
holiday High Jinks on the younger players
okay you got you guys are in charge of
setting up the net on the other side of the
pond all right you got you got it okay okay
yeah I'm sure yeah just never gets
old we forgot about the
Kraken whoa from there it's time to show off
game on incredible athleticism unbelievable
stick handling and well there's always one guy
who just spins as fast as he can that was so weird
all right let's go a truly magical night only made
more magical if they finally let the narrator play
too okay but yes a magical night enjoyed by all
wait I said by all where is Conor pad I definitely
gave him the address oh we're in hockey Pond
Hills I thought we were in hockey Pond Acres guys
guys I'm sure he's fine but like all good things
this night must come to an end sun's coming up
we got to go we got to get out here which is
probably for the best because I got to get to
another voiceover job about a bunch of accountants
who sneak out one night a year to do taxes in the
middle of the woods that was awesome next
year I'm going to spend more best night
ever happy holidays from the NHL